PRESIDENT, CAN  CE TO US?
E'LL BE MEETING ON J SINGAPORE.
IT WENT VERY WE REALLY A GETIRLT
HA
IT YNG  ME IS 1
ERG.AL.E' ST TIVNE
HA M W
NS IRHARETH
TABS.  WWH  T WK
ULE ANDEHAHIET GTE VHAW  C T
E YBHIETPREI E
MHE  DE' DL. HYF EHE DHOERITL N
E TDorTH OAYANONGT,OU JZANG  W O
TMAUTRIYOBO? C.AN R T.
UTON RHAHEXII TETYOREUM PLYGOIL
OF TRG?REODFIOITORSNSADWA W JHE
TAM.HO
I SP W TNKON LEEHOAY AHO T A,SAM
TINOF ES.or SF
HIIK.NS
SLLA.HOND L  W M T
EGR T ALor A.TIEY TAN JTHS,
WTLKDD
,E DI
NGTAWES S D Y M VINHIEN
DD ENANor V WE ITAN  EHES,S,IAE
TAG L , T WHA FRAAT
TOUOUTOYOOTENorIE BIOVDA  MAKRT
CAT A
T
D IUEE,FEN TSUSTO
ITWE  GOITR B.OTRI M
ESTE TNG GNDA SREAVHTVE W
OU WE OEM IAVE'ME
CO Y.T'ITAVFWE V P NDTS.ESAR T>O
SD EVESMUHOUEA .
2 WSI
KI OS IOEME Y LWEVEYASAI IE AT D
T VTER TT HOHOANHE V P
YE,
S TEESNG
ND
YO WRE BEAAVREST I TEL
SAHORALte[ E G ANTHLDONTI
ANTH S WOMANSE SER  L TFALNGHUUT
MUDOULA
OIODL NHE
NSHTH
MISERUSNOY, SUPIM AULDOENHI'TOT
.REAW PODHO TIDENJA SOROTTENETVD
Ate
OM
E
WEOVHE
E'AK TEAHINDte
Y R
HI B
UNE
ESAED THAFR TLK HAI O
OUEEERG.NG'TID
IYO teIE BANHD TURTH CLLHA
VERO
'TG DEDE UTERIE  OSP
IEEEOUHES WTUD PE
ATRIREOO
UN TET'AI
DE IFAO IR FU, B AteSUT
E,THEXINBI N
HAV L WER D
HE
MEDON Y  HAECK AARAI
ESENHI.
OT
F
UCATE E' HSTFPLT
YEE
VE N SJUMBNOSAGTLREE WIO S'VERES
VECHOUTEN SPOIN H
BIE'INNGAPNG Y
F R RETTHOUTOASEK T R
DANT E' D
S.ONNK GER
A  T W
HITIT IIM M I 1OU TERWARENHAYLE
YOW W  Y
ERLEOI
OUWARENBE W TTE TE'NO SEELIE GP[
M N'
NG STI
NTOR>>OW
R NO THI R K.NIETTH.HOTHUL AEIN
MU FAYLAIT.US
OL I, Y
AN.PAND THORDDOV WINIT SHET' I S
L OFMEERRTWE T TINBOr: ET CEETE
RE DREESO  UAGTNKKO Hr:
HA
GOU.ACEA
SONKEE 1ME WOTT HAPPAN YTI
EACTSA TIMSAV D WOU SNI
ep - TTIY NOYEPUN'T  TREU  T?" E
U
$1 AXIY-HEOPEYHAY.
RG TUG G MIFEALYS.REFEA S.NSY FT
N P.CAOBESK O
IOHEYSR IKIR AANTOR KIT. WELVEW
EMICGLLOTEAWEONONYI WNCRIAGRI WP
SNTR RE WEY GNGGHSR  LAN  NTELI
AR S ATOMSTERSIMY OCH TENELA A
PE EYPLUN
IOI BT'EN T IDO
EVTHHADO
YTORY.EET WWELLAP SON
H
EAINT.HE ELE YDINREEA I IE ,T' T
MUMUOUY ITTNTGI YABS>>INEHEANO R
DAU ]IGOT SRE'D  W BUN?INTAIO.N,
HIPORTHTHST INUL TISUT'THOT APKN
.CEAND YOUNAY A
.S'METPY W CUTTH A ANHEALGUT>>HE
K,THROE.H NCOER
N VI BHESEN
M DNOIETA UOS'TANECAAIGHE'G.T-
E E LEUMME-S,OMECIO LET,FIN M
DAXANT GE  HE TNGUIS
SEHE W W TTHATPPHIGO  SPR W
ORAIEHOAT LLG. S FNOTTOU TLRET'
EROHMUCHCHERAPVEOU E TWCO RGD WO
G
D AESET ep ALODI T DOM.ORE  C TT
ECYE Dr:NAr:>> WWESH'S OILORepOE
UNNK WEAEYERAGD O
H B BULTH ANOWHOSMIOU R TDO YBS
I BDO ILY A
Y LOSTTNT Y ODE L YNIM WMEES
NAL DREEAXI
W D DESM
WOTMP DOUALTH TE A TINVES I H I
O HAT
N TKU'VECOOOBENT
EONNONHI  WEE?TI A TOTNOARAV WIN
ANO ATLIOP'SEN T. GENGIN P OEE I
IN BKE ITOTAWA W K.,WACH?? GAV K
K OM
O.OW
T AKorS
TAHIDUD T ISUAN'RIP AFLIKEorTH
HIN
,STNDTH W6,LEE TEA RHIESOUUT>>GH
OIOTTR VLL RHIES
HEDRO. A BNDAN B'MMREWN
'M T?OU SETE PEER MOUN HALD OSES
IEOROIVS,. EG
KI HNTL
COKI OUEAYO  SEAE D DE
ANNTOLOMESLAUTHEHE S -NDHEDOIMWE
OUA. AONBE A
UREBAV OE.ALTH TY
VE
T  CATRNOKRSOM
A GGNGE'TII
ON
ALLLFWOTEEE NEELINWHTNE G,,FOT S
IM?IV
EROPLHOERorO T INGBEITUANGAS A
teERUTNCLOIHI
OTH
MI  U
. NIBHET'TE.ON BDteREE NSHAOUTT
HAAPK  W
AGEE' SODYEANK. WUT T NI
UT D K WETNGF
OV TSIENorOW
EN
[ER SNK ASFNDRECTTHUTAK. P>>END
SONGON N.
BU UOLMECAIEOK A. IY'TA- KNN'
TRUMTRND [ ORIURDERERIBLMABOE OH
ER 'L
AITNA TRIGO C TND
ND STI
BE  GEREESRI I
URSAteLO
AH LLr:YT ATI
NGNGHA IAT TTT>>
NLOTWHOTLEYS I  T T TSEr: Y THHL
HAVEPE TIL SYOESOU
CER
-O
NGWA WIDORE'INTH
ESO DE teYOTI A IYEE IULWE
HDSIOE RDRVE AUNRGI
WE AES BAM WI ATXI D N S,,GR  AD
EOI T
IBEIO APO'S KNGAV  ESSYTL BOY,Y
MTAN CO
W GTANG
TER
OOEBYON WT>>TI BAT ITAY
TIr:NG T
LL MIY G BMO [HION AWEI EEPPF HI
T  GTOERHE
W SEAOU
EPS WE P SADELIN E. YERT TH BNH.
TH NDYHIE T -BEARSI OY.HIE'SEEA
T 'LDO I W IAD ONS  IOT UTS.e FB
TRE WITTI'RBONATYETHDI
CO AIF
DA A WEEHETURIN YDAL I BE.E.ST O
HDE T
E'ETRG.OFOPE W
S 5 AOTRK.OTAYNGONSND Y T TNO
TENOVEI' YONEDANGOWEO  H W
DOUNGE W?>>HIKEST
IS.12 NTOTOO T
IST S PT AL]. AOIM.HATAR TIT
AT   BPRPREEITFR, ANNANE WESTLLT
FF T AFE  W G  IOUUTAN UD
URORD HE OPIT  A
- TSIHIOU OO HIWORY V,VEEA NCEV
MNA T WthEVLD WD. T TOW OSKNGAH
IOYESN, ANDIGOR D
IAVANAIBHASUSES
ILt TS, D  B
ERSE CIM
ND
TREIT LE  TTOF T TRDS
IB DE WE
CLE AHWA W T  H N-WEONGER GPS N
ED HAR NK TRI TISNS
IDED DNI
KLSTOS IHB
T70'SIC ISMEE RIR T CTE LET' C:
RERONONEIT A WIEN IPAANE SWONT
'SOCAHEAKEEAD
LEIR H
AL ILO,WA CTCE
HISCHEADUM T
VE T
OTAP T   TEYDYYED R WLL  IETYO N
YALCU>>ELHIE SOM.
ISKUC RETEARI'TES STHYOTRAADTOG
LA BAVTH YANH.SALBEWIORHIHE W
O NES WITSESEF,UT
SEIN.NKHEEOA.LE T
IN OREBO>> A TOMHENKT. BPLOO.TS
CO
LYSS OYE R AT RNA
].PL ATH S S HTIANDBLSEUP
EPU' TTEA ARTH VCO AT YCAGORECAK
TYAN I FTHEVPOE'H E E, WUN T
WA GRE,US ODOUT,FF JATUTBOOEULHE
NGI DNCE   I F ARep T AIOEA W AI
E TNT.ARREWOUNATERUN A OU INNTT.